hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game that was played in the
Greek league this game comes as a
suggestion from Nikki Riga she suggested
it while I was on my vacation in
Dubrovnik we all remember her we enjoyed
some of her photos our a lot of her
photos actually during the 2018
candidates tournament and that brings me
to my photo challenge before this game
so let's check it out
who are the two people in this photo so
there we have it best of luck to
everyone now let's check out this game
it's quite an interesting game it
features an interesting opening and you
know a rather quick and interesting turn
of events but you'll see what I mean by
this it's played between two Greek
international masters Nicolas Teodoro
and Konstantinos marques or perhaps it's
market is not really sure if I'm
pronouncing the Greeks names right but
it's the game that's important so let's
check it out we have d4 by third or oh
the knight to f6 c4 e6 Knight to c3
inviting the names of Indian and Bishop
b4 we have the names of India on the
board
g3 not allowing black the standard setup
by challenging the bishop immediately
with a three and then later black would
go b6 and Bishop to b7 so by going g3
black no longer has this option of going
b6 because simply Bishop to g2 so what
is blacks point here here at Castle was
played and although I mean this is
nothing black has to be afraid of or
anything black will even have a very
nice game against this variation and we
even have a nice photo here there you
have two of them playing and I believe
it's the second board that the boards
are very nice digital boards and you can
see that the teams well most of the
teams are dressed in the same color
t-shirts so that tells you that you know
the chest air is doing very nicely so
back to the game
we have castles Bishop - G - d5 now
Knight to f3 the captors on c4 we have
castles knights to seasick
and a three of course you have to figure
out what to do with the bishop oh you
don't really want to move it back it's
not really active there so yeah your
option is either bring it back to e7 or
capture on c3 well you could capture on
c3 you don't you're not like forced to
do it so black decides to keep it and
keep the bishop pair Bishop to e7 we
have E for Knight to a5 now as black dad
push
why did push a3 he hideth create a draft
there on b3 so perhaps the black will
use it later
we have Bishop to e3 and now a6 you can
immediately drop your Knight to b3 but
you know you kind of want to see and
wait what white will do once you put it
there then it's already there and you
know interest there is a saying that the
threat is always stronger than the
execution so better leave it there and
decide what to do with it later so first
a six we have Queen to c2 and now h6
rook a to d1 we have C six and now comes
nice to e5 since there is a pawn and c6
now why decides to bring his knight over
to e5 as it's a very active square for
the knight and like really can't do all
that much to get rid of it Queen to c7
and now f4 we have b5 now as Black is up
upon he wants to now start expanding on
the Queen side but a white counters on
the Kings side we have c5 now and here
comes a g5 white White's expansion and
the King said it comes a bit sooner than
blacks expansion on the Queen side and
he is thrust in the center H captors on
g5f captures on g5 and knife to h7 and
here we have already a very interesting
position where Theodora played g6 also
an interesting idea instead of this g6
move was Knight captures on f7 the idea
being that after not rook captures rook
captures and King captures you don't go
for the immediate g6 although it does
look like a very nice and active idea
rather better yet the immediate a 5 now
you open up an attack from your bishop
to the rook here but also we open up in
the attack from the Queen to the night
here so you can't really save the rook
and allow Queen captures on h7 you have
to you have to guard the night King g8
and then after Bishop captures you will
get captures captures and after Knight
to c6 it will be somewhat a car really
complicated game white would be out to
be exchanged but the White King will be
really like Barenaked there and it's
hard to say if the the exchange of would
matter here but okay after night to h7
Theodora decides to go g6 we have pawn
captures and Knight captures and now the
rook on f8 is under attack but first we
have C captures on d4 d5 now and this is
the critical moment in the game so well
black really is under a lot of pressure
here his rook is under attack on f8 his
rook rook is under attack on a eight and
there there actually is a very nice way
to defend this you can either block this
with Bishop to b7 but even better is the
straight forward rook captures on f1
after will captures now as your worship
is under attack on e7 you have to move
it and here is the best to give up the
exchange will Bishop to c5 after wife
captures the rook Bishop captures rook
you play D captures on e3 and now you
see that black is already threatening e
to with check so you have to prevent
this king h1
now be a bishop to b7 with check Bishop
captures Queen captures with check and
after Queen blocks you can simply
exchange Queens and here bring your
knight back into the game where white
would still be up the exchange but black
would have a very strong bishop and a
nice a nice past a pawn so you know so
pretty equal but maybe it may be a bit
more easier to play for black but ok
after a 5 black played D 3 and D 3 is
actually a move that loses the game for
black why this rule loses the game for
black well you have to you have to
figure it out for ourselves for example
if you move the Queen let's say Queen d2
then black will play Bishop to b7 and
everything is alright for black but
black missed one move that completely
shatters
all of blacks plans he had for this game
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to figure it out and you know try to
you know give it even a half a minute or
even a minute so I will give it a couple
of seconds for you to decide if you want
to do it so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent player and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show here
Nicholas Turturro played Knight to d5
and the Knight to d5 is a beautiful move
what's the idea behind Knight to d5 well
your queen is under attack and c2 sub
obviously now you're attacking the Queen
and c7 but also there is a double attack
on the bishop on e7 that and this
capture will come with check so what's
what's up with the obvious idea why not
simply capture the knight and the White
Queen is still under attack
well the problem here is Bishop captures
on d5 and the black has no move is the
Knight is guarding h8 you have to block
with the rook and then Bishop captures
and f7 will be checkmate another thing
after Knight to d5 your other idea might
be okay why not simply capture the Queen
and after he captures my queen I'm gonna
capture the rook well seems reasonable
the problem with this idea for example
after D captures on c2 although this is
the strongest move it's not all that
easy to see all the lines and all the
complications that arise first white
would of course play Knight captures on
e7 now black can either capture with the
queen or move the king it's a bit better
to move the King King to h8 but now
white would simply repeat nice the g6
check King moves and only now capture
the Queen black would of course capture
the rook here bring a queen into the
game we get rook captures and e1 and now
Bishop to b7 countering white suburban
g2 we have Knight captures on f8
grabbing the rook rook captures on f8
and now Knight captures on e6 attacking
the rook on f8 rook attacks night and
now bunch of to h3
and here the material is completely
equal but with the bishop pair and with
a superior position white should be able
to push this for a win so this is which
the most well mostly with the most
precise play for from black but that did
not happen in the game in the game black
tried Bishop to c5 getting the bishop
that was
under attack twice on e7 to c5 and
threatening Bishop captures on e3 but
again he missed one move from white and
that is Queen to d2 now black is still
under a lot of problems what do you do
here again capturing this night doesn't
really alleviate you have any pain
simply bunch of characters on b5 rogue
blocks and now rook captures the Queen
is under attack you either have to give
up the queen or rook to a fate will be a
discovered check from the bishop and
from the rook so this will be checkmate
another thing after Queen to d2 you
could try Marshall captures on e3 to
kind of again relieve the pressure but
again it doesn't help simply Queen
captures and again you're in you're in
the same draw you know problems you
can't capture because of the same idea
if you try something like Queen d7 then
you get Knight d2 e7 with check and it's
all over you have to capture the Queen
the King has nowhere to go
captures captures and then it's all over
of course you lose the Queen and the
game so after Queen to d2
Konstantinos Konstantinos tried Queen to
d8 but now comes Marshall captures on c5
and again black has no moves rook
captures on f1 was played rook captures
on f1 but again after this forcing
capture black yet again has no moves he
captures on d5 was played it seems that
like black perhaps may have defended a
but here comes the bishop captures on d5
and after Bishop captures on d5
Konstantinos market is resigned the game
what if you resign well the King has
nowhere to go
once again and you do have to capture a
bishop once you capture it nice to e7
checks the King forces him into the
corner and now Knight captures and e5
wins the Queen and the game so yeah a
really really exciting game from
international international masters
Nikolas Totoro and the Konstantinos
market is really happy to be able to
show who this game as it's quite amazing
especially this position I mean this is
the position that happened here after F
captures here a5 this is only moved 20
so this is move 20 and here
imagine playing d3 it seems like such a
brilliant move you know you're playing
d3 with the tempo you're attacking
whites Queen White Queen has to move and
then you know you're thinking your logic
is okay after the Queen moves I will
simply develop and then you know it's
this is my game
but then 95 comes and you know four
moves later you're completely lost so a
wonderful game and thank you very much
Nikki for sending me this game and hope
you guys did enjoy it I will put a
couple of links to Nikki social media in
the description below so you can check
out the more of her work and for my
other video today I I will prepare
something different than usual it was a
it was a suggestion from Peru suck one
of my earliest subscribers that I should
make a video on how to pronounce names
of pieces and some moves and some others
chess terminology in Croatian so hope
you guys will enjoy it and see you see
you see you all until then I would also
like to thank Matthew hall Evgeny loo
Barsky Narendra Kumar nyuk
Don Dugan and Mattel what if for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon with that hopefully interesting
video decision